we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
this is really funny someone called in
about on a live stream a couple months
ago i recommended a particular ice cream
this is a fantastic ice cream it's okay
the brand is called it's either greytons
or graters let me actually see i want to
get it right
is it greyton's ice cream
greyton's
ice this is not a sponsor
graders okay graeter's ice cream i've
been a lifelong cherry garcia fan
but i don't think it's actually that
great i just didn't know of other cherry
ice creams
greyton's black cherry chocolate chunk
ice cream maybe the best ice cream i've
ever had i mentioned it on the show all
sorts of people now are obsessed with
this ice cream take a listen to this
hi david i've been a member for
oh my god over a year but i want to tell
you i tried on your recommendation
graters black cherry ice cream and it's
excellent it beats cherry garcia out of
the water absolutely beat something out
of the water thanks for everything you
do i appreciate your time your
um
and everything that you do for us i
appreciate it take care yesterday i
tried to get myself some of this
grater's black cherry chocolate chip ice
cream
um
it's the one flavor that was gone from
the grader's shelf i went to my grocery
store
and i went and i said sir where is the
where's the ice cream they said here it
is sir
and there's a there was graters and they
had black raspberry and they had vanilla
and then i just see an empty space and i
look at the tag and it says
black cherry
the black cherry
is sold out
i'm not taking responsibility for this i
think i stumbled upon this as many other
people were stumbling upon it as well
uh but i can't get my hands on the black
cherry ice cream so in the future i'm
not going to be mentioning any products
that i'm interested in buying because it
doesn't seem to be going super well in
terms of my ability to get them but
fantastic ice cream not a sponsor just
good ice cream and i think like a dozen
people have told me david this this ice
cream is amazing we've got a great bonus
show for you today
the fed plans to ban
policy
policymakers
from owning individual stocks and this
is an issue we've been talking about for
a long time the personal financial
interests of members of congress
number two
ron desantis radical trumpian florida
republican governor governor of florida
and florida which makes it even crazier
he's going to give five grand signing
bonus or wants to to unvaccinated police
that are quitting other police
departments in other states to come be
cops in florida
okay
and then lastly texas lieutenant
governor dan patrick who offered to
start handing out rewards for people who
find voter fraud he has finally paid out
his first reward to a democrat
for identifying identifying voter fraud
carried out by
a republican
you've you love to see it you really
love to see it all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show uh sign up at
join pacman.com
you've got to spell it correctly i get
emails sometimes from people who say
david
your membership website has a virus
if you spell my name wrong it will take
you to a different website that i don't
know what's on it okay join pacman
p-a-k-m-a-n.com
sign up coupon code
felony21 the code is such a big discount
it should be a felony but it's legal
okay felony 21 is the coupon code sign
up at joinpakman.com
and we'll see you on today's bonus show